the number of people hospitalized with
flu like symptoms is now the highest
it's been in almost a decade new numbers
released by the CDC show an estimated 51
out of every 100,000 Americans have been
admitted for the flu this season our
doctor Tara Narula he's here with the
impact of this unrelenting epidemic Tara
good morning good morning John while flu
activity is easing up in the West the
rest of the country remains at high risk
the elderly are being hit the hardest
and the death toll continues to rise at
least 53 children have already died 16
of those died last week alone everybody
is devastated as you've never expected
to happen to you
an Indiana family is in shock after the
sudden death of seven year old Savannah
Jesse the local coroner's office
confirms the first grader tested
positive for influenza strep throat and
scarlet fever before she died
Courtney Hargett is Savannah's aunt he
was so smart smartest little girl you
would ever meet she's always so funny
and fun-loving she was really a free
spirit her father found her unresponsive
one day after taking her to the hospital
after they left the hospital he took her
home put her in bed and then found her
these cases are becoming more frequent
in Virginia 7 year old Kevin Baines died
just one day after testing positive for
the flu and six year old Emily muth from
North Carolina died three days after an
influenza diagnosis both children did
not get the flu shot it's very important
if you notice that a person is getting
better from their flu and then suddenly
gets worse for them to seek medical
attention the signs of getting worse
would be difficulty breathing that
suddenly comes on or spike in the fever
a dominant and dangerous strain of the
flu virus h3n2 is partly to blame for
the nationwide outbreak a recent
Canadian study found that the flu
vaccine is only 17% effective at
protecting against h3n2 it wouldn't
surprise me if we find the same thing
here in the u.s. even with low
effectiveness against h3n2 viruses we
think it's very important to be
vaccinated there have been more than
126,000 confirmed flu cases
but officials say we still may not have
reached the peak of this outbreak and
there is a financial strain as well this
flu season could reportedly cost us
businesses more than 15 billion dollars
in productivity loss Gail why no silver
linings in this story at all thank you
very much Tara